gonna be honest with you is probably
going to be more of a gush session let
me know that you know that don't piss
off just yet stick around but let's take
a feed in the machine that is that
YouTube algorithm but I'm just saying
that's a bloody good time
[Music]
so evil dead Rises a new Evil Dead film
it has Bruce Campbell and Sam Raimi as
producers but Lee Cronin directed this
one there's his family in this really
crickety creepy apartment which is a
great setting for a movie like this one
of them finds This creepy book like hey
Book of the Dead
sounds great then whoops the blood hits
the fan now when I saw a trailer for
this one people seemed really excited
and I was like it seems like just
another horror movie another
demon-possessing people has that really
dank dark pick your Blum House picture
it kind of looked like that but make no
mistake they saved all the great
raymie-ish flavor for the film and that
was amazing to see I'm not saying in
that Nostalgia bait kind of way though
it is nostalgic to see that for this
world absolutely it also does have some
fun nods too evil dead but it doesn't
rely on that what I'm talking about is
some of the camera work Parts in here I
was like are you sure raymie didn't
direct this the title segment for Evil
Dead rise itself I was like are you sure
Remy didn't direct this if not for
continuity's sake just for the sake of
enjoyment and fun while watching the
movie completely worked for me and I
thought everyone in the movie did a
great job Lily Sullivan's essentially
the hero of this film she's the cool
ants who's forced into this situation to
try to get her nieces in nephews out of
this situation because well their mom
has died and become big evil the kids
were great in this movie to the point
where I want to be like does the studio
cover the therapy bills just just asking
just seems important to ask that but
Alyssa Sutherland as dead possessed
demon mom was the film yeah being an
effective demon like this is not just
about contorting or floating or
Screaming but being vile and mean enough
to say the meanest things to the people
in the room knowing it cuts that deep
mom let me let the maggots down that's
hurt I'm gonna be honest with you there
were moments in here I was laughing I I
wasn't laughing at the movie I was
laughing because the demon she was
having such a good time I couldn't help
but have a good time before you go out
there being like Oh Jeremy said it was a
comedy let's do it and you yourself find
yourself in a therapy session blaming me
for that I'm not saying it's a comedy
I'm not even saying the movie's funny
I'm saying when there are characters and
actors on screen having a good time I
find it infectious and I'm likely to
have a good time I guess that also
translates to Demons tormenting an
entire family
I don't know what to say or maybe I'm
not Jeremy anymore maybe Jeremy's with
the man good smell she's a demon that
checks all the boxes playful frightening
Sinister scary not relying on jump
scares or I can't think of a jump scare
in this entire thing I'm just saying she
was such a [__] [__] in the movie
couldn't help but enjoy myself there's a
psychological warfare element when
tormenting a family when it comes to a
demon doing that I think a lot of horror
movies just kind of skip past that part
they're like all right let's get to the
jump scares this movie doesn't it plays
it smart it does it effective it does
what it does well and yes this movie's a
complete and total bloodbath absolutely
if you got to the end of Dead Alive and
you were like that was a good time I'm
sure you'll love it if you enjoy
measuring your on-screen blood volume
not in gallons but elevators full found
a movie for you now this movie's not
going to be for everybody absolutely but
if you're an evil dead fan or generally
speaking a horror movie fan this one
stands out right with the camera work
the violence I thought this movie was
incredibly imaginative the movie's not
that long it's an hour 40 minutes but
there is a point where I was like if it
ends now that would be great it's still
going it's starts going on ridiculous
the movie was 10 minutes shorter I don't
mind saying it would have been perfect I
didn't know what I expected from this
movie what I got was the most enjoyable
horror film I personally have
experienced in years this is a film that
was crafted to be part of that annual
Halloween horror movie bash that you
have with your friends and it's worth
watching and worth buying on Blu-ray
alright so evil dead rise have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
foreign